the only problem with the john wick
movies is that there aren't more of them
if you need your fix of action pictures
with thoughtful world building and
plenty of style here are some other
movies like john wick you need to watch
before you die
released in 2006 crank stars action
stalwart jason statham as chev chilios
an assassin betrayed by an upstart
hitman who wants to take his place while
asleep in his apartment chelios is
injected with a synthetic poison that
suppresses his body's production of
adrenaline gradually killing him unless
he can keep his mind racing and is hard
pounding chelios must do whatever it
takes to make his search for an antidote
as intense as possible that means
speeding cars getting into shootouts and
in one instance engaging in an extremely
public sexual encounter
crank is a lot like its protagonist if
it slows down that means it's over
first-time directors mark neville dean
and brian taylor pace and edit the film
like a wild video game with each stage
and set piece more outrageous than the
last statham's performance is easily the
most unhinged of his already explosive
career and his rampage across los
angeles is nothing less than a bloody
delight as felix vazquez jr wrote in his
review for cinema crazed it's trashy
gory gratuitous ridiculous completely
far-fetched and i had a smile on my face
the entire time a sequel called crank
high voltage was released in 2009 in
which chelyos has his heart replaced
with a mechanical device that requires
constant jolts of electricity to
continue working
director michael mann is no stranger to
stylish crime thrillers having directed
such hits as heat and thief however it's
safe to say that his 2004 film
collateral is certainly among his most
stylish and thrilling collateral stars
tom cruise is vincent a hitman with a
gun and a list but no wheels when
mild-mannered cab driver max played by
jamie foxx picks him up he becomes
vincent's unwilling accomplice driving
him all over los angeles so he can
assassinate some big shot criminals it
only takes one body dropping for max to
realize he's made a terrible error in
judgment but by then it's too late as
vincent holds max at gunpoint and forces
him to finish the job you killed him
no i shot him bullets in the fall killed
him
what starts out as a simple fare turns
into a chaotic night of chases standoffs
and plenty of shootouts it's not at all
mindless action though vincent and max
have some fascinatingly tense
conversations on the road life death
dreams fate all are topics that the two
discuss as they travel from hit to hit
both crews and fox give captivating
performances throughout and actors mark
ruffalo jada pinkett smith and javier
bardem round out an all-star cast
charlize theron stars in director david
leach's high octane feature atomic
blonde which was released in 2017 and is
based on the graphic novel series the
coldest city by anthony johnston the run
plays lorraine broughton a deadly mi6
agent sent to berlin in 1989 to retrieve
the list a stolen compendium of all the
names of spies operating there before
the entire intelligence community is
compromised james mcavoy sophia botella
and john goodman also star with its
saturated hues and exceptionally
choreographed stunt work atomic blonde
drew plenty of comparisons to john wick
when it was released which makes sense
considering leach's role as an executive
producer of the franchise although it's
set in the world of espionage and covert
operations there's plenty of bombastic
action throughout including a
particularly stunning stairwell fight
taken in a single unbroken shot anchored
by theron's killer performance and a
pulsating soundtrack of familiar late
80s jams atomic blonde makes for a good
double feature with any of the wick
films
when director writer john wools the
killer was released in 1989 one of its
taglines was one vicious killer one
fierce cop ten thousand bullets though
that last part may be a bit of an
overstatement there are certainly plenty
of shell casings littering the scenes in
wu's hard-boiled tale a professional
killer ah jong played by chao yun fat
zhong's own moral code dictates he take
one last assignment in order to secure
funding to help sally yes jenny a woman
he accidentally blinds during one of his
hits on his tail is inspector lee ying
played by danny lee the killer is filled
with all of wu's filmmaking trademarks
standoffs shootouts slow motion and
plenty of sentimentality even though the
killer contains gnarly action and gore
it also contains some beautiful
reflections on the nature of
spirituality and humanity john may be a
hitman but he'll go out of his way to
protect anyone who might be caught in
the crossfire the dance-like action
sequences alone make the killer worth
seeing but the emotional dynamic between
zhang and yang makes it something truly
special to behold
written by john wick scribe derek
colstad and directed by ilya nyshiller
of hardcore henry fane 2021's nobody is
a wild ride filled with mayhem murder
and a kitty cat bracelet starring bob
odenkirk as retired auditor hutch
mansell nobody wastes no time getting to
the good stuff that being fights
shootouts and stuff blowing up real good
this fast-paced film fits a lot of
action into its 92-minute run time even
managing to be a bit touching by the end
mancell has a quiet life boring job wife
and kids but it's really interrupted
when their home is invaded by two
robbers he lets them get away with his
watch and some cash but comes to regret
his decision over the following days
after channeling his regret into a
violent altercation on a city bus
mansell finds himself the target of a
russian mobster and his crew little do
they know mancell isn't actually much of
a nobody after all and neither is his
father who's played by christopher lloyd
during a twitter watch party for the
premiere of nobody naishula tweeted if
you approach the character as if he's
addicted to violence and has kept
himself in check for 15 years then the
film will really click for you odin
kirk's man cell is wound up tightly and
once he's unleashed there's no stopping
him just like wick
not all contract killers do it by choice
some are forced into the life by
circumstance
as happens to nikita in le femme nikita
this film released in 1990 stars anne
parriot in the title role and was
written and directed by french filmmaker
luke bisson pario's nikita is a debulk
teen who murders a police officer during
a robbery gone wrong after her arrest
rather than being put on trial she is
given a choice by the mysterious center
be reborn as an assassin or lose her
life nikita chooses to become a contract
killer a vocation that she seems to have
quite a talent for nikita is worth a
watch for parrio's performance alone as
nikita is transformed from a derelict
criminal to a femme fatale a female
assassin who's both terrifying and
sympathetic
the film has been remade twice once his
black cat in 1991 and again his point of
no return in 1993 the latter remake
stars bridget fonda in pario's role the
film has also been adapted twice as a
television series 1997's le femme nikita
in 2010's nikita needless to say nikita
has hit her mark
although charles bronson had already
established a long and varied career as
a supporting actor by the end of the
1960s it was his output in the 70s that
cemented his status as a leading man in
1972's the mechanic bronson stars as
arthur bishop a well-regarded assassin
or mechanic as they like to call him
whose violent profession has led him
deep into a spiral of anxiety and
depression much like john wick bishop
works for a secret society with its own
set of laws break those laws and face
dire consequences after killing harry
mckenna one of the organization's big
bosses bishop gets to know mckenna's son
steve and decides to teach him the
tricks of the trade behind his
employer's backs turns out steve is a
very good learner so much so that bishop
may not only have his bosses to worry
about frequent bronson collaborator
michael winner directs this surprisingly
nuanced take on the business of death
bronson shares the screen with his
real-life wife joe ireland 70s
heartthrob jan michael vincent and dr
strangelove star keenan nguyen the
mechanic was remade in 2011 with jason
statham and ben foster and the bishop
and steve rose respectively and was
successful enough to yield a sequel
mechanic resurrection in 2016. it's hard
to beat the original though for both its
portrayal of the mechanics of
assassination and the humanity of its
characters
before spy kids and elita writer
director robert rodriguez began his
career with el mariachi starring carlos
gallardo as a particularly unlucky
traveling musician who finds himself a
victim of mistaken identity arriving in
a new town with nothing but his guitar
el mariachi isn't looking for trouble
however he finds it when the notorious
killer azul known for his guitar case
full of guns escapes from jail raising
the ire of the drug kingpin moko
unfortunately for el mariachi the hitman
moko sends after azul can't tell the
difference between the criminal and the
performer and chaos ensues even when el
mariachi finally manages to escape the
action he finds himself roped right back
into it after falling in love with
moko's love interest domino gallardo
stars alongside consuelo gomez reynold
martinez and peter marquardt who all
give enduring performances rodriguez's
kinetic style and flair for the dramatic
propelled this tragic tale of a man who
wanted nothing more than to be a
musician only to have his dream
shattered in the most painful way
the spanish language el mariachi was
made with no second takes on an ultra
low budget of just seven thousand
dollars the film's two sequels 1995's
desperado in 2003's once upon a time in
mexico were given significantly higher
budgets and feature antonio banderas
taking over the role of el mariachi
gallardo didn't seem to take the
recasting personally however as he
served as a producer throughout the
trilogy originally intended to be a
single four hour film quentin
tarantino's kill bill was split into two
features with the first chapter kill
bill vol 1 released in 2003 kill bill
volume 1 stars uma thurman as the bride
an assassin shot and left for dead at
her wedding after her former associates
massacre everyone in the church when she
wakes up from a coma four years later
she proceeds to wreak harrowing revenge
on everyone involved on that fateful day
lucy lou vivica a fox daryl hannah
michael madsen and david carradine also
stars the other members of the deadly
viper assassination squad as in john
wick the assassination squad has a
strict code of conduct that its members
must abide by one which the bride seems
to have violated tarantino's
appreciation for asian action cinema
rapid fire dialogue and impossibly
bloody violence are on full display as
the bride methodically hunts down the
traitors who destroyed her happiness the
first volume is highly stylized and
follows the bride's journey from
hospital bed to snow swept japan as she
prepares to battle her former colleague
oren ishii as roger ebert put it
tarantino's story is a distillation of
the universe of martial arts movies
elevated to a trance-like mastery of the
material tarantino is in the zone kill
bill volume 2 was released in 2004
wherein the bride finishes what she
started
while most films involving contract
killings are deadly serious in bruges
goes in a bit of a different direction
released in 2008 and written and
directed by martin mcdonough in bruges
is a pitch black comedy that features
colin farrell as hitman ray brendan
gleeson as rey's partner and mentor ken
and ray finds as harry their boss rey
and ken are in hiding because rey
recently botched a hit accidentally
killing a child and harry is absolutely
livid about it after all killing a child
violates the hitman's cold as rey and
can cool their hills in bruges belgium
harry tasks ken with taking care of rey
but ken's not too keen on that plan
harry doesn't appreciate ken's
disobedience so he heads to bruges
himself to get his hands dirty it's only
a matter of time before things come to a
bloody head in bruges finds a lot of
humor in a lot of places from a colorful
cast of supporting characters to the
profanity-laden tirades from its leads
farrell and gleason have excellent
chemistry constantly playing their
characters new roses off of each other
mcdonough also responsible for 2012's
seven psychopaths in 2017's three
billboards outside ebbing missouri
teases non-stop laughs out of a bleak
predicament infusing the story of a
bunch of killers and re-probates with
plenty of well-earned heart
the assassination bureau limited given
the snappier title of the assassination
bureau in the states also takes a darkly
comedic look at the hitman business but
without all the bleakness of inbruge
based on an unfinished novel by jack
london this 1969 picture stars oliver
reed as ivan dragamilov diana rigg as
sonja winter and telly savalas as lord
boswick winter is a journalist and
women's rights activist who discovers a
secret organization of assassins aptly
titled the assassination bureau limited
instead of exposing them in her capacity
as a journalist winter decides to have
the head of the bureau dragomilov killed
believing that a power vacuum would
dismantle the entire enterprise from the
top down she does this by soliciting a
hit on dragomilov from his own agency a
request that dragamilov surprisingly
accepts there's other conspiracies at
play however as newspaper baron lord
boswick has his own sinister plans to
take over the bureau the whole thing is
intentionally ridiculous and overly
complicated but a very fun watch
nonetheless
the second take on the hitman genre from
luke baison leon the professional was
originally released in 1994 as just the
professional in the u.s this time jean
renaud takes center stage as leon the
titular professional killer who finds
himself the guardian of 12 year old
matilda played by natalie portman it
hasn't exactly aged the best with
certain scenes ranging from problematic
to downright creepy but the film is
worth checking out for its explosive
action scenes and compelling revenge
narrative matilda and a family live in
the same apartment complex where leon
resides when matilda's drug-dealing
father runs afoul of gary oldman's loose
cannon dea agent norman stansfield
matilda returns home one day to find her
parents and siblings slaughtered in a
violent raid leon takes matilda in and
when she learns the truth about what he
does for a living she convinces him to
teach her the tricks of the murder trade
so she can avenge her four-year-old
brother over time leon and matilda form
an odd bond he teaches her weaponry and
tactics while she plots to take on
stansfield all by herself portman is a
tiny powerhouse of emotion and her debut
performance is a taste of what was to
come later on in her career renault is
also quite good at being a likable
killer and oldman often seems like he's
in a different movie from everyone else
entirely but in the best possible
way bring me everyone
what do you mean everyone everyone
matilda isn't the only adolescent
assassin on this list in 2011 circa
ronan played the title role in hannah
about a 15 year old girl whose father
teaches her the ways of the hitman
hannah's father eric an xcia operator
played by eric banner is being hunted by
his former employer because he knows too
much to protect his daughter eric does
what any loving father would do he
starts training her how to kill while
she's still in diapers he has motors of
his own however as he sends her off to
kill kate blanchett's cia agent marissa
wagler who's been sent to clean up
eric's loose ends hannah twists and
turns as the young assassin undertakes
her mission and discovers a dark secret
her father has been hiding from her for
her entire life hannah marries action
with coming-of-age drama with ronan
showing off the skill that had already
earned her an oscar nomination for best
supporting actress several years prior
director joe wright keeps the tension up
and the pacing tight as hannah heads
straight into a reveal that will turn
her entire world upside down a tv series
based on the film also called hannah per
made on amazon prime in 2019
john woo's groundbreaking 1986 hong kong
action film a better tomorrow is widely
considered the film that turned chao yun
fat into a superstar in asia chow plays
mark a high-ranking member of the
criminal triad alongside his friend
seung se ho played by t long things are
going great but there's a problem hole's
brother kit is a cop hell-bent on
stopping the triad hole wants to go
straight but as is always the case
during that one last job things get out
of control and he's sent to prison when
he's finally released after three years
ho discovers that his gang has had a
change in management his former
apprentice shang has usurped mark as the
boss
wu minds the tension between ho's
dedication to his brother and his
allegiance to his best friend while
meditating on what makes a family albeit
with a healthy dose of his trademark
bloodshed the relationships between hog
hit and mark make up the emotional heart
of the film a sequel a better tomorrow 2
was released in 1987 and a prequel a
better tomorrow 3 love and death in
saigon in 1989. the latter was directed
by troy hark after he and wu had a
falling out a better tomorrow has also
gotten its fair share of remakes with a
1994 hindi version called atish a 2010
korean version and a 2018 chinese remake
a better tomorrow 2018. check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]